good morning John today's episode of
lovers is brought to you by the number 7
Billy and yes I know that discussing the
extremely important and pressing issues
of global population while suffering
from contact signing psychosis is a
little silly but that's just the world
we live in I have to show you my shirt
than that amazing eye I just had this in
my closet I didn't even go to the thrift
store okay probably I should not do this
entire video wearing this mask I should
at least give you something to like make
a Jif out of while you're watching this
video it is entirely possible that the 7
billion person is being more of course
we won't know who exactly that person is
that that'd be pretty cool get him a
shirt says 7 billions and it's also like
a 10% chance that there will be a 7
billion person and then someone will die
and then there will be another 7
billions person but it's all statistics
at this point because it's very
difficult to count the number of people
in the world so 7 is a lucky number I'm
excited about that 7 billion I'm not so
sure to be clear I have a problem
talking about the problem of population
ego geek we are some people who leave
comments aying well this wouldn't be
necessary if there was just a smaller
population I have two problems with this
first there are lots of things that
would solve all of our problems like the
trees suddenly started making
electricity or we could eat air all of
our problems would be solved and it's
useless to talk about because there's
only one way to decrease the number of
people that we currently have in the
world and that's for them to die and
hopefully you're not advocating for the
death of billions of people because I
think we can all agree that that's not a
good thing if you don't agree with me on
that point you freed it stop watching
these videos because I don't want you
around evil person the other problem was
saying that population is the problem is
that every one of those 7 billion people
is a person and when we think about them
not as people but as problems that need
to be solved as mouths that need to be
fed and not as what they actually are
which is amazing powerful forces for the
betterment of the world for themselves
for their children and for everyone that
not only objectifies those people but it
diminishes our ability to come up with
real solutions to the problems that we
face because I'm not saying that there
aren't problems here we have problems
last year we created enough food to feed
11 billion people and yet of the 7
billion people we have a billion of them
struggle with hunger so
what is up with that well about half of
that food was fed to cows chickens and
pigs so that's a problem fresh water is
the most important ingredient keeping
people happy and healthy and it's
becoming more and more scarce but
there's also good news birth rates are
down to 2.5 babies per woman which is
very nearly replacement rate use of
contraception is up dramatically disease
rates are lower poverty rates are lower
education rates are higher overall we're
doing surprisingly well especially with
you know what we expected the world to
look like 40 or 50 years ago I am
actually very hopeful about the future
of our species yeah we have immense
challenges to face but we have immense
resources to face them with it all adds
up to what will probably be one of the
most exciting and vibrant eras in human
history and yes also potentially violent
and dangerous but I for one feel
privileged to be one of the seven
billion people that gets to live through
it John I'll see you on Friday it's
green it's been a while since I've done
this you may have noticed that my goatee
is looking fine in preparation for
Halloween and you'll be finding out who
I'm going to be for Halloween very soon
in my next video you can guess in the
comments if one of you guesses it I
probably will just tell you that you
were correct and you can feel good about
it
there are some other things to click on
here there's an amazing truck song by
dr. noise you have to watch the end
because it's epic and there's some good
Hank game stuff going on some Swindon
Town miracles and some Hank and gather
and play and Super Mario Brothers Wii
and there's a episode of truth fail that
I did last week about October holidays
but anyway gotta go dftba